foreign
[Music]
so we're gonna go ahead and get started
um while I'm chatting feel free to still
use the Q a to introduce yourself and
say where you're zooming from if you
haven't gotten a chance to yet we want
to go ahead and get started uh because
we have some great information that
we're really excited to share with you
so again welcome to the Visa q a session
with Stanford's Bechtel International
Center I'm Jessica from the MBA
admissions office and joining us today
are two advisors from Bechtel junco who
is the assistant Dean and assistant
director and Hannah who is the sevis
manager you can go and Hannah thank you
so much for joining us today and if you
want to go ahead and give a brief
Welcome to our students I'm sure they
would love to hear from you
all right well good morning or good
afternoon a good evening my name is
Jacob Perry I'm the assistant director
for the international student
immigration advising
Anna
hi everyone and my name is Hannah and I
am responsible for issuing your Visa
documents and she's gonna be your best
friend
yeah you'll be seeing Hannah and I a lot
probably over email and just making sure
that we get you through the Visa process
as smoothly as possible uh so thank you
Hannah and junco so much for joining us
they both have so many years of
experience supporting International
students across the entire Stanford
University and we're so grateful that
they were able to make the time to join
us today
so for today's webinar it'll have two
parts the first part will be an
information session so junco will share
with us a brief overview of the Visa
process to kind of build a foundation or
starting off point so we can have our
discussion and then the second part will
be a q a session where we'll try to
answer as many of your questions and
address any concerns that you may have
in the meantime we do ask that you hold
on to your questions until we get to
that second q a portion of the webinar
some of your questions may be answered
during junco's presentation
um so we really just want you to kind of
sit back during the first part and take
in all the information and then we'll
get to the Q and A's after uh junco I'll
go ahead and hand it over to you now so
the floor is yours all right let me
share the presentation
all right can you see okay
yep all right
so let's get started
um so next 30 minutes or so we are going
to talk about uh different types of Visa
F1 and J1 mainly and we're going to talk
about arriving at Stanford what you need
to know about come to stop here and
overview of durational status and types
of F and J1 employment
um and again we're gonna have a q a
session followed by the brief
information session
I'm going to share a lot of information
with you but don't worry you don't need
to memorize all of it you just need to
go to backdo.com for the edu and if you
click immigration and a Visa type on the
side you are going to find all the
information I'm going to share with you
today on the website
let's talk about the different Visa
types
um there are two main Visa type for
students one is F1 and then the other
one is the J ones the restriction and
the requirements are pretty similar for
iPhone and J1 Visa but there are slight
differences
one is about employment uh the types of
work authorization that students are
going to apply and the duration of a
going to get is slightly different and
then we're going to talk a little bit
about the employment issues later on
and then the funding
um not everybody is eligible to apply
for a German visa in order for you to
become eligible for J1
50 or more of the funding source has to
come from non-personal funding source
so actually majority of international
students at Stanford is here as a F1
students
um some J1 students Master German
usually sent by the funded by the
government or funded by the company back
home
and so for oil outside scholarship
if you have a dependence and there are
slight differences in dependent benefits
if your dependent your spouse is here as
a F2 then they are allowed to study
part-time but they are not allowed to
work in the U.S if your spouse is here
as a G2 then they are allowed to work
and study in the U.S
and then just you know the comparison
chart is on our website as well
um there are a couple things that you
have to do before you can come to the
United States and I know that a lot of
you are itching to get the visa
documents start this process right away
but actually it is still a little bit
too early we are going to start the Visa
documents issues sometime in March
and that is because we have to wait for
the University to publish the tuition
and the health insurance fee for the
next academic year and then that usually
happens towards the end of February so
again the whole process is going to
start in sometime in March
um if you are going to come to Stanford
as a F1 student then you are going to
apply for I-20 if you are going to come
here as a German student then you are
going to apply for this 2019 and I20 and
it is 2019 at the Visa documents that we
are that are issued by our office and
then these are the documents that you
need to have with you when you go to a
visa interview at the U.S embassy
so let's take a look at the Overflow
um you are accepted to Stanford
congratulations and sometime in March
you are going to get the invitation to
Bechtel connect Vector connect is the
online portal the students can use to
apply for I-20 or this 2019
you'll be asked to upload the passport
copy the funding information and also
acceptance letter
once you submit your application through
backdoor connect we are going to review
your information and then we are going
to issue your I20 or this 2019.
and you are going to get notification
from US once your document is issued
if you are getting an I20 from us then
once you get the email notification that
your I20 is ready you will just need to
go to backdoor connect download your I20
print it out and assign your I20 and
updated and then that's the document
that you are going to bring it to your
visa interview
if you're getting a this 2019
unfortunately you do not have have the
option to go to the back door and then
download the ds2019 we actually require
to mail you the original DS 2019 to you
okay so you are going to receive the DS
2019 mail
once we get once you get the I20 or
ds2019 you're also going to get the link
to the Stars training this is the
training that talks about why you need
to prepare for the visa interview and
also what you need to know about how to
maintain your legal status once you get
to Stanford
okay well it is not mandatory but we
strongly encourage everyone to complete
the training
once you had the I-20 or this 2019 then
you are required to pay a distance
course seriously
um there is required for everyone to pay
uh if you are coming here as a F1
students then you the CVS fee is going
to be 350 dollars and if you're coming
here as a J1 students the CBS fee is
going to be 220 dollars
once you pay the service fee and have
the I-20 in this 2019 then you can go
ahead and make an appointment at the U.S
embassy
um for the visa interview you should
bring your passport by 20 funding
information and acceptance letter okay
uh once you complete the visa interview
there'll be the officers and the
consulate officer is going to review
your applications and determine whether
you are eligible for F1 or J1 and then
they are going to put a jail on stamp or
F1 stamping passport
once you have the Visa then you are good
to come to the United States
um as a F1 student or German student you
are allowed to enter the country up to
30 days before the program started
once you enter the country we do
strongly encourage everyone to go to
this arrival information page it's a
government website and to make sure that
you are admitted as F1 or German student
I briefly mentioned about the backdoor
connect
um as I mentioned sometime in March you
are going to get an invitation from our
office for backdoor connect
um you just need to go to backdoor
connect desktop for the edu and it's
going to ask you to create an account
and it just you know the step by step
um instruction can be found on a website
if you're getting I-20 the I20 it's
going to look like this and for J1
students you're getting the ds2019 which
is looks like this uh once you have the
documents it is really important that
you check all the information is correct
not just the spending of your your name
versus uh country of citizenship but as
um but also the academic information and
if there is an error please reach out to
us immediately
um
if you are not Canadian then everybody
is required to go to a U.S embassy and
apply for a Visa if you are Canadian
then you are exempt from the visa
requirements so you still have to go
through the Port of Entry and the
present on the documentation but you do
not need to make appointment at the U.S
embassy in Canada and then go through
the process but like I say unless you're
Canadian everybody will be required to
make appointment at the U.S embassy and
go to the visa interview process
once you get the visa in your passport
again it is really important to check
all the information is accurate and also
the Visa type is is correct
once you have all the documents then you
have to get ready to come to the US
right
um to enter the US you will be required
to have a valid passport ideally valid
for at least six months past the program
ending unless your home country has a
passport agreement agreement with the
U.S
you also have to have a F1 and J1 Visa
unless you're Canadian
I20 in this 2019 again for F1 students I
know you can get the soft copy of I-20
but you would need to print it out and
assign it and date it at the portable to
present at the portable entry
we also
um recommend that you have a proof of
funding can be a bank statement can be a
letter of a offer letter for a
scholarship or
um
the bank statement of a family member
who is going to be supporting you
we also recommend you to have acceptance
letter with you so these are the
documents you have to have with you so
don't put in your suitcase you have to
have it in your bag so that you can
present it at the Port of Entry
and as I mentioned earlier I as a fun or
German students you are allowed to enter
the country as the F1 org on students up
to 30 days before the program starts day
so I believe the MBA program starts and
sometime in the mid September so you are
going to be allowed to enter the country
sometime in August
if you need to come to the US earlier
than that so let's say in July you want
to come here a little bit you can come
here as a tourist
but you do need to deport the US and
then we enter the U.S as Afghan or J1
students
um up to 30 days before the program
starting
we do have a lot of great information on
our website about how to prepare
yourself
to come to Stanford
um we do have a great two weeks
orientation in some September and we are
trying to publish this orientation
schedule in July
um or earlier hoping for earlier
um but yeah we recommend students to
check out our website check out the
orientation information so that you can
join the sessions
okay let's take a look at the duration
of status
um this is the period that you are
allowed to remain in a country
this is for F1 students
um so number one is the time that you
are pursuing your program at Stanford
if you happen to do internship during
your program you are going to apply for
work authorization it's called CPT
okay and then once you're done with your
program then you have a 60 days of grace
period where you can start working in
the U.S
um as a F1 students you are eligible for
12 months of opt where you allowed to
work in the U.S and also because you are
getting a stem degree in the U.S you are
eligible for 24 additional months of
work authorizations called stomach opt
so total 36 months you are allowed to
work in the U.S in a PW study
once you're done with the opt or stem
extension then you do have additional 60
days of grace period where you can pack
up and go home or go to different school
or change your status to different Visa
type
and if you're a J1 student this is the
period that you are allowed to remain in
the country again during the time that
you're studying at Stanford
um and once you're done with some
program then you are allowed to have a
30 days of grace period where you can
start working in the U.S under academic
training this is the work authorization
you can apply as a J1 students and then
you are eligible for up to 80 months 18
months and then once you're done with
the academic training then you do have a
30 days of grace period again where you
can pack up and go home go to a
different school or change your Visa
status
all right
um then let's take a look at the
employment options for you for the F1 or
J1 students or fnj1 students are allowed
to work on campus
um if you are coming here as a German
students then you do have to apply for
work authorization to our office but
again everybody is allowed to work on
campus
if you are here as F1 students and want
to work for off-campus employment then
you will need to apply for work
authorization
and the type there are mainly two types
of work authorization one is character
practical training and the other one is
optional practical training
just so you know as a F1 students
um in order for you to become eligible
for any off-campus employment you have
to enroll at least one academic year at
Stanford
okay
um and again we do have a lot of
workshop and a lot of information on our
website about what you need to know and
what you need to do to apply for
authorizations so once you come here you
have a plenty of opportunity to get the
information that you need
um there is also a separate work
authorization for students who are going
to be working for international
organizations
um this is for F1 students
um it is rare but it happens
um so if you find a job opportunity
International Organization such as World
Bank or iMed then please come and see us
and we can give you the information you
need to know
um if you are JY students then you are
eligible to work off campus then you do
need to have a work authorization and
you're going to be applying for a
workout Edition called academic training
um let's talk a little bit about the
on-campus deployment because everybody
is eligible for on-campus employment
um during Academic Year you are not you
are allowed to work up to 20 hours a
week during a vacation time you are
allowed to work more than 20 hours a
week
um once you graduate then you have to
have opt or academic training to work
even for on campus okay
um the on-campus employment is defined
as services that you are you provide
directly to student population or sample
populations
okay and mainly the payment comes from
Stanford okay
um just because you are here on campus
you cannot just work for a meta or
Google remotely that's not considered as
on-campus employment okay if you have a
question if it is considered as
on-campus employment or not then please
come and see us
if your F1 students you don't have to
get work authorization to work on campus
but if you are J1 students then you
would need to get work authorization to
work on campus
and I just wanted to share some links
with you
um that is really helpful information
for all the unity and um newly automated
students so please go ahead and check it
out if you have a questions
um you can answer and email us there is
the email address on the bottom but just
be aware that that email address is
currently not active it's going to be
active studying sometime in February
um and if you have any questions about
um I20 DS 2019 or the Visa process then
you can certainly use the email address
to ask questions
all right
um this is it for my part uh welcome to
Stanford we are so excited to see you in
September
thank you so much Funko for sharing that
information uh really helpful even I
learned a lot as well
um so now we're going to transition to
the Q a portion of the webinar so please
go ahead and use the Q a function
to ask any questions that you may have
you'll also be able to upload questions
that other students that other attendees
are asking if it's something that you
are also interested in learning about
and we're going to get through as many
questions as we can I also wanted to
note that we did put a lot of different
links in the chat uh the links Legend
code just shared in her presentation as
well as some others that may be helpful
so you can find that information there
but go ahead and uh just feel free to
use the Q a function
and I'm also going to put in our MBA
admits email address which everyone
should have but if you have a question
that
um
about let's say like financial aid or
and how that impacts anything or you
want to ask a question before the new
international grad email address is
activated you can go ahead and email us
at that new admin email address
um perfect okay so we have our first
question uh so the question is if I do
an internship having a J1 Visa uh will
the academic training time after
graduation be 15 months or still 18
months
so the academic training is available
for 18 months for the durational J1
status so if you are going to use uh
three months out of eight 18 months for
internship during the summer then you're
going to have a 50 months left after
graduation
hey thank you
um and then our second question if I
have a startup post graduation how would
the Visa situation work then yeah great
question
um the F1 students
um are eligible to apply for
post-completion opt after graduation and
then that will allow you to start your
own company you can be self-employment
during self-employed during a
post-completion opt
um there are some restrictions for
stomach extension but we can talk about
that once you get here
um but um J1 students under the academic
training you are not allowed to be
self-employed
hey thank you junco
uh so next question is uh does the 20
hours per week rule apply to unpaid work
too for example unpaid internship or
working on a personal venture
yeah I'm paying internship uh yeah I'm
pretty sure it's kind of in it it's
interesting topic I know that a lot of
students have a question about that but
yes
um even for unpaid internship depending
on what you're going to do if you are
going to let's say
um volunteer work at the Red Cross or
Habitat Humanity or like
um some charitable activities in nature
then that it's considered as a
volunteering work and you do not need to
apply for work consolidation it will not
be counted towards 20 hours a week but
20 hours a week at a startup or doing
your own your own company then yes that
will be counted towards the 20 hours a
week and you will be required to have a
work authorization
great thank you and I do want to jump in
um and just let everyone know that the
MBA program office will not approve on
campus work during the first year of the
program because they really want
students to focus on academics so if
there's anything and we'll get into this
because I do see an H-1B question
um so if you're on a Visa status that
requires program approval
um for employment that's not something
that the MBA program will give
um so that ties into our next question
um
which is one that I think I'll start off
with and then throw it over to Hannah
and junco if they want to add uh so
asking does the international office
offer help and or guidance about the
situation about my current Visa in the
U.S for example H-1B what's the best way
to get connected and get more help
um so I just want to touch upon real
quick
um the H-1B visa and then I'll go ahead
and throw it over to you junco and
Hannah
um
so if you have H1B sponsorship we first
encourage you to connect with your
immigration attorney and employer and
confirm that they are okay with you
enrolling in a full-time program for
your MBA
um like I said uh previously the MBA
programs offices expectations and
policies regarding employment is that we
do not approve any employment during the
first year of the MBA program so if you
require any kind of approval for
employment from Stanford or the GSB we
will not give that approval that's
because our program is designed to be a
full-time program with courses
activities policies and expectations
designed with that in mind faculty are
also not willing to excuse absences or
make any concessions to support students
with professional obligations this is a
really strict policy and we really don't
make exceptions so we do strongly
encourage you to consider the MBA
program expectations and policies as you
make your decision
once you decide please go ahead and let
me know
um whether you're enrolling in the H1B
because based on your final decision we
will need to make a note of that in our
records so we know not to expect an I-20
or a ds2019 request from you
that's how do you want to jump in with
anything
um I think you covered pretty much all
but yeah if you are switching it to F1
or J1 then you can certainly reach out
to us you will need to apply for a 20 or
DS 2019 and we we can help you with the
process itself
great and do you actually want to talk a
bit about
um like staying in the country versus
leaving the country if you're wanting
from an H-1B sure yeah if you are
switching from H1B to F1 or J1 there we
do strongly encourage students to do so
through traveling so the party in the
U.S making an appointment at the U.S
embassy obtaining a fun or German visa
and entering the country as a final J1
there is a possibility to change
immigration status within the U.S
however the process can take really
really long time so and we do actually
encourage students to work with
immigration attorney to go through the
change of status process and
um to be frank with you I we do not
usually recommend students to change
immigration status within the U.S
great thank you so much
another question is where do we indicate
our preference for J1 versus F1 visas uh
that might be a best answer by Hannah
so as we as junko explained in her
presentation you will receive an
invitation via email and once you log
into our portal through the invitation
email you will get to a application and
uh on the in the application you will
find that uh the question the field
about the Visa type so you can choose
either F1 or J1 there
hey thank you
uh next question uh if a student's wife
is on an F2 Visa can she work on campus
or with International organizations and
can she work while the student is on
their opt
yeah that's a great question
um unfortunately F2 holders are not
allowed to work in the U.S period so if
your spouse would like to work in the
U.S then she would need to secure her
own Visa type that will allow her to
work in the U.S
great thank you
uh next question is uh oh actually I'm
gonna okay so I'm gonna ask this
question because it's a little related
if I will be married by September 2023
how does the Visa process for my partner
work
okay um
we
you can request for a Visa documents if
you're going to be married for sure
um you do not have to be married legally
married at the time of the application
for I-20 ideas 2019. however by the time
the you and yours partner will go for a
visa interview you have to be able to
show a marriage certificate
um but you can go ahead and submit the
request for your dependents while you're
submitting I-20 or ideas 2019 request
form
great thank you
next question is are there any
requirements on money made from
Investments overseas I hold a variety of
stocks and will likely have capital
appreciation over the two years
um I'm not quite sure what
um you mean by any requirements
um F1 students or J1 students are
allowed to have passable income so you
can own a stocks that it is not a
problem
great thank you
okay
uh let's see
okay I think we're caught up for now but
go ahead and keep using the Q a um for
any questions that might come up um I
did want to talk a little bit about uh
how financial aid is factored into the
Visa process
um because that's something that will be
um you'll be working closely with the
MBA admissions office and our financial
aid office
uh so uh for round one students if you
submitted your financial aid application
by January 2nd you will receive your
estimated financial aid award letter by
January 27th so tomorrow this is going
to be an estimated award letter because
the cost of attendance will not be
finalized until March so the estimated
award letter could include GSB
fellowships student contributions or
international student loans these are
funding sources that you can use for
your Visa process so for example if
you're eligible for a GSB Fellowship you
can list that as a funding source you
could also list your international
student loans as a funding source when
you fill out your I-20 or your ds2019
request form this does not mean that
you're obligated to take that amount of
student loans but just that you're
eligible to borrow up to up to that
amount so these are all sources that you
can present to Bechtel as funding
sources for your Visa applications
if you haven't applied for financial aid
yet you're we still really encourage you
to do so just at this point it's a
rolling review process so it may take
three to four weeks to get your
estimated Financial reward letters but
you can complete your I-20 request form
when you receive that estimated
Financial award uh when you receive your
final financial aid award letter uh in
March when we calculate the cost of
attendance
um
Let's see we have another okay so we
have a quick follow-up question so can
the spouse of F1 work during the opt
period with an F2
unfortunately not
there you go thank you for answering
that and then
[Music]
um
but then what about for um a J-1 Visa
right so your spouse is here at the J2
then he or she can apply for work
authorization and once
um here she has a work authorization
then they're allowed to work in the US
great thank you
so yeah F2 dependents cannot uh work in
the US but then J2 dependents could
um
so you're welcome if anyone has more
questions about that
um we did include the links that kind of
talk about the differences between F1
and J1 a piece of that as well is going
to be the funding
um how how you get funded so for the F1
Visa you just need to demonstrate
funding for the first Academic Year of
the program for the first nine months of
the program which is about 125 000.
for single students and about 150 000
for married students that's based off
the cost of attendance for this current
year so we'll have the numbers for next
year available in March uh funding for
the J1 is different so you need to show
funding for the full program so that
would be both years plus the summer in
between
uh so that total cost for a single
student would be about 262 thousand
dollars
and 51 of the single student cost of
attendance must come from fellowship
sponsorships or scholarships
um so if anyone has more questions about
that we're happy to go into more detail
because I know kind of calculating that
funding can get a little complicated so
we're happy to talk about that
um I will say about 95 to 98 of our MBA
International students do come in on an
F1 Visa so that is
um by and far the most common Visa that
our students are on
yeah I'll give everyone another couple
minutes just in case you're thinking
about anything
um
and then junco Hannah do you have any
um just general advice that you would
want to share with our students about
the Visa process anything that
um gets asked really frequently or
students kind of come to you and say
it's something that they wish they would
have known or something that you want
our students to know ahead of time
yeah I mean I would definitely encourage
everybody to start the visa application
process as soon as it becomes available
make sure that you have all the
documents ready so that as soon as
specto connect opens then you can go
ahead and submit the request
again we are Hannah is going to be
dealing with a lot of newly unmitted
students so it might take some time for
our office to process I-20 or this 2019
um but it is again really important for
you to submit the request as soon as
possible for you
um and once you have that 20 ideas 2019
then you can use the CBS ID number which
you can find on a 20 or DS 2019 on the
top Corner
um and you can use the number to make
appointment for a visa interview
so as soon as we issue a Visa document
we email you guys the series number so
you don't have to wait till you get the
physical ds219 to make the appointment
you just have the email and then you pay
for the CVS number and make the Visa
appointment
right yeah and that's uh make sure that
if you I mean for all students but
especially students who are applying for
the DS 2019 that we have your updated
mailing address
um just because that's even though
you'll have the cheapest number um
through email you'll still need that
physical form
um we do have a question I think this
will be for Hannah
um can we make a U.S visa appointment
without an I-20 to Fast Track the
process and make sure we get it in time
you do need that Visa um the I20 ideas
2019 to make appointment
yes
yeah and unfortunately we can't get the
I-20 to you early because we will need
the cost of attendance for next year
um but having it in March and being able
to kick off the process there should
give it should be plenty of time yeah
and also don't worry once you submit
your application our office process your
application pretty quickly so it takes
only
a couple of days I mean five to ten ten
days but yeah we'll process your
application quickly yeah and uh if you
are coming here as a F1 students then
you don't have to wait for the actual
document to be mail you can just go to
backdoor connect and download it so the
process itself is pretty quick
and make sure to print it though yeah
exactly when you come to the US
perfect thank you
um and then the question is can I apply
for my Visa and then some months after
added dependence or should we apply at
the same time
um it is especially if you can apply at
the same time but yeah but it is
possible dependent later on
great and then I have a question
um if
funding do you funding documents need to
be translated and how does it work with
currency uh foreign currency
so I mean I Googled but you don't have
to you don't have to translate you don't
have to translate your funding document
but as long as it has to have the total
amount available amount on the document
but if you want to be really nice to
Hannah which is highly recommended yes
thank you I would definitely have a
document in English and if you have the
conversion listed on the on the
documents to a US Dollars
um that will that's gonna help Hannah
tremendously yes you're gonna get your
documents quicker that way
um and sorry just so you know the
funding information has to be uh less
than six months old
six months from when they apply for uh
application yeah got it perfect and if
your family members are supporting you
then definitely we need to have a
supporting letter from your family
members
along with their bank account documents
yes
yes I know we're giving you a lot of
information uh pretty early in the
process I know it's kind of hard to sit
on it until March when everything kind
of gets kicked off but we just want to
make sure that you have all the
information that you can um going into
Advent weekend for those of you who
applied for financial aid by January 2nd
you kind of understand uh what the
letter means and how that impacts your
Visa process
um and then we'll have plenty of time
um once March comes around Hannah is
super quick at processing documents um
and Hannah and I will be kind of
throughout your entire process checking
in seeing how it's going getting your
interview and all of that just to make
sure that everything's as streamlined as
possible
uh so we'll go ahead and give you guys
another couple minutes in case you think
of any last minute questions
um I'll go ahead and put
um our MBA admin email uh in
actually it's right there at the bottom
of the chat so you guys have that I
would go ahead and make a note of it it
should be in the my gfb as well
um if you guys think of anything
um as well as our Visa page in my GSB
portal it has a ton of really good
information so between that and the
Bechtel website
um really all the information that we
covered is going to be found there as
well
um and then let's see another question
are there things other than the Visa
that as International students we need
to bear in mind or take action for
um good question
can you think of anything Hannah
I don't know
um
maybe Visa I think that's the only yeah
I mean obviously that you have to have
the visa to enter the country
um
I don't know if you are thinking about
opening up a bank account in the U.S or
getting a driver's license in the U.S we
will have a session on how to get a
driver's license in the U.S or how to
open up a bank account or apply for
Social Security number
um or file tax return uh once you get
here it's going to be covered during
orientation
and when is that um so sorry one of the
orientation typically take place junco
so we are finalizing the uh the schedule
right now but usually happens
um
two weeks prior to the start date or the
Academic Year
perfect so they'll be able to enter the
United States 30 days before and then
about two weeks before the program will
be the orientation yep that's correct
um another question is I know sometimes
pregnancy can affect getting a U.S
tourist visa excuse me if my partner is
pregnant while applying for the F1 F2
Visa would that cause an issue
um it should not cause an issue but it
will cause an issue if you
um just so you know open a German
non-immigrant internet Visa so you
cannot have an intention to immigrate to
the U.S
um and if you indicate that you have
intention to immigrate to the U.S during
the interview then your visa application
is going to be most likely denied so
just be careful
about being pregnant itself it's not
going to be a problem that's a great
point Thank you for emphasizing that
because that's something that we've
encountered in the past with a couple of
our students
um
and then that's something that for the
pregnancy that the partner would
disclose kind of during the application
or the Visa process
um you don't have to volunteer any
information but if you are asked a
question directly then do not lie and
just be honest and answer the question
great
uh and then do you have any resources or
advice on starting a company as an
international student is there anything
I can do to work towards starting a
business while at the GSB without
violating the terms of the F1 I love
that question
just so you know
um you are here to study have fun in J1
Visa uh here for studying in the US so
that's the government's expectation
right um the government expects you to
focus on a study not about working or
studying your own company in the US so
there are a lot of restrictions about uh
starting your own company as F1 or J1
students
um but we do time to time invite
immigration attorney to come and talk to
students about uh what are the options
after your study at Stanford
and different Visa type that you can
explore to work in the U.S
yeah and I would say from the MBA
program side of things once you arrive
you're going to have the support from
our career Management Center so the CMC
for additional guidance because we know
a lot of our International students have
these same types of goals and we
obviously want to support you within
what we can do within your Visa status
that's a great question
okay
[Music]
so uh
let's see we've had a lot of really good
questions I appreciate all of you
attending and interacting with us
uh we are going to go ahead and uh
start rep oh perfect we have another
question okay so I have a directorship
role for a company internationally I
don't intend to actively work but I
would so technically be a director could
this be an issue
uh it can't be I mean again you cannot
be working in the US at all as if on
students for the first Academic Year
um so if you are going to be taking a
leap of options then you might want to
get a letter from an employer confirming
and verifying that you are not working
at all why do you are pursuing your
study at Stanford
and having that for the interview
process yeah yeah
great
that's a great question as if you know a
lot of our International students they
already have really executive roles and
are doing great things abroad exactly
you would need to stop doing that why do
you are here
you want another minute in case there
are any
last-minute questions
otherwise we'll wrap up
yeah I know a lot of students will have
a question about employment but as I
mentioned we do have
um Workshop throughout the Academic Year
and the students are encouraged attend
so that they can ask questions remember
we are here to help you
definitely Okay so
uh let's see okay
so thank you both um Hannah and junco so
much for joining us and thank you all of
our admits are joining us today
congratulations on your admissions to
the Stanford MBA program we're very much
looking forward to welcoming you to
campus in a few months you know that
time's just going to fly by
um Chico and Hannah thank you so much
for sharing your expertise with us today
if there's anything that you want to say
in closing feel free to uh go ahead take
the floor
okay look forward to see you guys and
then don't hesitate to contact me at the
the email address if you have any
question yeah and we are so looking
forward to meeting you in person
hey thank you so much so I know we're
faster protein admit weekend so we look
forward to seeing you in person or
virtually in another couple of days for
those in a Time Zone close to California
we hope you have a wonderful day and for
those of you heading into the evening we
wish you a good night thank you so much
for coming and take care
foreign